yves bubry shenzhen mpd massène sène
en attendant la mention j'aime de vos
faces de karen pour le cache trop de
flash trop de buzz mousse gros des plus
hauts de montreux
[Musique]
mais là ça peut continuer jean leloup
merci pour la leçon de guitare mais j'ai
amené le même avec cette dit enregistrer
votre nouvel album
ouais ouais je me promenais avec la
guitare pendant ces trois ans que je me
balade ben que j'avais envie
d'enregistrer quand je compose
ça me tentait d'enregistrer quand je
compose pas passer par l'étape préparer
aller en studio je voulais vraiment
enregistré loulou
puis j'ai traîné des enregistreuse avec
moi des petites enregistreuse 8 peace
love des fois je traînais des microbes
je mettais des arbres amis croule pour
enregistrer puis je me suis baladée
venait aussi d'oiseaux et info news en
grand c'est l'effondrement peas a fini
aussi au costa rica dans charlevoix dans
une quête est et en asie mais je posture
parce qu'il est tellement des milliers
trac mais je me suis baladée puis je
trouver la meilleure formule 2
musicien sera un jardin de ma mère
ce sont les oiseaux tout l'été pour la
première fois vous avez une chanson sur
votre mère ouais vous avez senti ce
besoin là je m'en remet un arrêt à la el
alem sofa son jardin el alem les jardins
et puis mon père il y avait un mais lui
c'est le fleuve voir le fleuve les
grands espaces lui c'est alors il
regardait le fleuve donc j'ai lu ment
pas et il est mort il ya un art un peu
plus et puis quand je revenais chez nous
bon en fait quand je suis venu chez nous
j'étais comme je regardais un putsch à 0
kg et plus
puis je me suis mis à jouer de la
guitare puis je me soumets à parler de
jardin de ma mère puis du jardin de mon
père avec ça parle des deux des deux des
deux jardins de chacun de mes parents je
sombre et habitudes de voyage pauvre
garçon auquel j'ai assisté à votre
concert le fantôme de paradis city à la
salle wilfrid pelletier de la place des
arts ce test est magnifique je connais
bien m'a dit je pensais vraiment pas que
j'étais capable en cage no7 chaud j'ai
pas pensé à mon affaire terminée j'ai
réalisé que j'avais annonce un chocolat
du temps c'était vraiment dans ma tête
oui justement schuller c'est devenu que
c'est tellement plaisant à faire que je
me suis dit ok choix un album à la
guitare puis se met à penser aussi à
monter des chaumes où j'aurai des du
théâtre des acteurs de théâtre et puis
des personnages des trucs comme ça dès
16 h au théâtre assez éclatée fait que
cet album ghost recon à la base en outre
m je sais pas trop à quoi bon expliquez
moi votre technique de picking parce que
les accords 500 aux chansons mais c'est
tout et dans ces quelques dans le lit tu
regardes les secrets bombe chez lui m la
guitare en fait c'est petit à petit si
tu sais pas c'est pas comme ça ces mots
c'est ici alors cette légende habitue
sponsors
jamais des caps sont bons ce qui vous
même mais moi j'ai pas capable c'est
qu'elle joue du bon peuple et le poignet
il ya en fait pas beau c'est surtout le
beau c'est comme ça je parle d'être au
premier plan bien passé quand il s'est
fait un peu normal ça avec le prêtre
quelle folle vitesse par hambourg puis
après ça le jean leloup qui était
souvent sur le parti disparu est ce que
ça vous permet d'écrire de meilleures
chances mais partie non ta n'est pas bon
pour le parti pour parler mais ça vous
permet d'écrire de mer chansons des plus
focus et ouais ça donne ses fans aussi
tu peux faire plus de voyager tout ça
est beaucoup plus de trucs à faire puis
mais en fait vraiment le jeu peu
compliqué à l'autre fois de suite en
voyage puis on pourrait s'imaginer que
c'est des choses extraordinaires
sinon je me trouve cabane puis je
m'envole matin je marche le long de la
mer puis là je marche assez longtemps
pour être bien fatigué puis le ch
content puis en général je peux rester
longtemps longtemps dans la lune mashish
jeu plutôt plate quand le loup
merci merci beaucoup bakou on ne sait
pas pourquoi
on ne se souvient pas de l'étrange p
on aime et on
nommé